lewin TSA's of such economists as Adam
Smith John Maynard Keynes and Milton
Friedman this 50-minute event was part
of the foundation for economic education
national convention last month in Las
Vegas I'm Joanne skousen I'm the
director of education at the foundation
for economic education my husband mark
skousen is our next speaker mark started
his career was the CIA as an economist
and an economic analyst and he has also
been teaching economics and finance at
Rollins College for the last 15 years
until sep tember when he became the
president of the foundation for economic
education in Irvington New York he's
written several books on economics
including economics on trial puzzles and
paradoxes and economics excuse me a new
textbook called economic logic and his
latest book the making of modern
economics published by any sharp and the
focus of this talk today the making of
modern economics is a controversial new
history of the lives of the great
economic thinkers beginning with Adam
Smith it's already in its second
printing and it has been translated into
a dozen languages mark blog the foremost
authority in the history of economics
calls it extreme but unputdownable
Foreign Affairs magazine called it both
fascinating and infuriating David
colander of princeton university calls
it irreverent passionate entertaining
and mischievous Richard Swedberg of the
University of Stockholm says it is one
of the most original books ever
published in economics James audison
professor of philosophy at University of
Alabama comments that scowl sins history
indeed reads like a novel or a detective
story and I was delighted to see Adam
Smith as the hero of his story skousen
is opinionated but he is honest enough
to give objective summaries of his
opponents and shortcomings of the
economists he likes I can only say bravo
and Steven capes of the Australian
Chamber of Commerce reports I couldn't
put it down the musical accompaniment
for each chapter are a wonderful touch
humor permeates the book and makes it
accessible like no other in history it
sets the standard so with that let's
find out what they're all talking about
with mark skousen and the making of
modern economics
thank you very much Joe and it's a
delight to talk about the making of
modern economics I think the first thing
that I'd like to do is to talk to you
why I wrote this book because if you go
and look in the library if you've ever
taken a course in in the history of
economics you'll see that dozens of
books have been written on this subject
however I would say that the vast
majority of these books have two
problems with them one is the content
they tend to be very incomplete they
leave out a lot of great economists and
I think it's due to their bias a lot of
bias exists in these histories of
thought I'm not sure why but it does
seem to be a problem the book that is
the most popular book that's ever been
written on the history of economics is
called the worldly philosophers by
Robert Hale Broner and how Broner is has
written a delightful history it's fun to
read but he leaves out major characters
and these are characters that he
apparently is not particularly
sympathetic to so he simply leaves them
out and the classic example of this is
in the new edition of the worldly
philosophers not a single word is said
about Milton Friedman of the Chicago
School of Economics now imagine Milton
Friedman was very close to being voted
by time magazine as the economist of the
century they gave it to Cannes and I
think rightly so but the editor-in-chief
of Time magazine felt Milton Friedman
deserved the economist of the century
and so here's how a broner writing this
book and Friedman's name's not even
mentioned so if you were a student
reading about economics you wouldn't
even know who Milton Friedman is and I
think that's a travesty so one of the
reasons I wrote my book was I wanted to
include people who should not be ignored
whether I agree with them or not so
certainly I don't think much of marks
an economist but I have a big chapter
about marks and it would be absurd for
me to ignore him the other thing that I
found was that the theme there was no
central theme in the history of
economics it was a hodgepodge of well
here's what one economist thinks and
here's what another economist thinks and
there's no no storyline no line of
thinking as to well here's the right way
here's the right path so to speak and
here's how these economists fell away
from the right path and here's how they
got back on the right path there's none
of that kind of story line in the story
of economics so there is no story in the
worldly philosophers or any of the other
histories of thought it just kind of
drifts along and I felt that this was
this was unfortunate not that it could
be remedied I had to ask myself was
there a story of economics so I have a
one slide I wanted to show my first
slide here this is the traditional
approach that's used as in political
science there's the what I call the
pendulum approach to telling the story
of economics and that's where you see a
economists portrayed from left to right
and so you have marks as the radical on
the extreme left and then you have Adam
Smith on the extreme right as the
conservative and then canes as these are
the big three in economics Adam Smith
canes and marks and so you have canes in
the middle as the liberal middle of the
rotor and this is the standard approach
that's used the problem I have with this
is that with the pendulum approach the
extreme left in the extreme right are
two extremes and they both appear bad
and so therefore perhaps the best is
where the pendulum rests which is of
course in the middle where Cannes is and
so most economists would say yeah that's
that's appropriate and I had some real
problems with that especial
the equator Adam Smith's view of the
world with Karl Marx's view of the world
so I decided that I didn't think that
this was an appropriate approach and so
I took a very different approach and if
you look at the next this is the
approach that I took in which i called
the totem pole approach to economics and
so I've reversed things I've changed
things quite a bit here i have adam
smith and his invisible hand vision of
economics that really the founder of
modern economics as the head in the
traditional indian folklore the the
greatest chief is on the top and and and
then it goes down not not denying that
all of these economists aren't great
they are great economists and they made
great contributions to economics
nevertheless adam smith in my opinion
should be at the top and why is that
because countries that have adopted the
Adam Smith vision of free market
capitalism or democratic capitalism if
you will have basically been vindicated
by history they have the highest
standard of living they have more
leisure time they have more material
goods and services and I actually think
the quality of life is better among the
countries that have adopted a small
government not a totalitarian government
on the other hand those that have
adopted a Marxist view and yes he was
primarily a critic of capitalism but he
also was a strong believer in socialism
and central planning in countries that
have adopted heavy doses of socialism
and central planning have simply failed
time and time again so I don't think
it's fair at all to equate marks with
Smith and so I foot our Karl Marx as the
low man on the totem pole so to speak
and then we have canes in the middle as
a interventionist on the macro level who
also seemed to adopt lays a fair on the
micro level so I felt he deserved to be
in the middle ground
but under under Adam Adam Smith so this
is the approach that i have taken now
one of the things that i tried to do in
my book the other the other problem with
the history of economics is that it
really didn't do a lot for students
there were never any photographs of the
economist she really didn't know what
they looked like he didn't know whether
they had four arms or 22 or four legs or
what have you if they were really real
people most of the books talked about
their their theories and didn't really
get into their lives so I tell a lot of
things that are rather unusual about the
economist a lot of people don't know
that that Adam Smith burned his clothes
one time when he was the customs
official and at the end of his life he
burned his paper so I call him the first
pyromaniac economist so we had a lot of
fun with the economist I have lots of
illustrations and photographs and the
other thing that I did was I i had i
selected classical music numbers and i'm
going to play five of them here during
my presentation of music that I've
selected to represent each of the
economist so the first one if Tim you
can turn on the music for the first one
this is the music representing Adam
Smith and his great book The Wealth of
Nations which came out in 1776 which for
we as Americans a very prominent year
that we all remember as the Declaration
of political independence but it was
also a declaration of economic
independence with the great book The
Wealth of Nations which really
established modern economics so this is
the music I've selected for him
it's simple powerful and beautiful
representing the smithy and model of the
invisible hand anybody recognize this
it's not the Olympics
coplin fanfare for the common man okay
so so that's the first selection and
yeah just not the next one not the next
just the first okay so what I've
discovered with putting Adam Smith at
the top of the totem pole was that I had
a story line instead of before this
hodgepodge of economists and what they
were saying I now had a hero and heroic
figure from which we could draw a plot
and the drama is over this basic
ideological plot if you will that Adam
Smith represented as a heroic figure and
that ideological plot is the invisible
hand doctrine I want to explain just a
little bit of what i mean by the
invisible hand doctrine because it's key
to understanding all the other
economists marks and canes and and and
everyone else this that's discussed in
in my book the making of modern
economics so what is this invisible hand
doctors only mentioned one time one
sentence in a 800-page book The Wealth
of Nations and basically what Adam Smith
said was the private acts of self
interested individuals would lead as if
by an invisible hand to the public good
private selfish acts of individuals
leaving leading to the the the public
weal the benefiting the common man and
so what what did we mean by that what
did he mean by that and he actually
meant it as a as a a religious symbol
because God is invisible how many have
seen God very few on earth have seen God
you see he's invisible and yet we
believe many of us believe in God and
some people have
a lot of faith that God exists others
have a little faith and some have no
faith that God exists and he thought
this was a wonderful symbol of the
capitalist system the quiet private acts
of individuals they're engaging in
commerce every day they're not on c-span
they're not on NBC or CBS or ABC but
we're all out there doing a variety of
things and it's leading to this this
common good or is it you see it's like
an invisible hand and so we have all of
us in this room have varying degrees of
faith on whether capitalism leads to the
public good or not some believe that
some have a lot of faith in freedom
libertarians generally have the most
faith that the individual acts of
private citizens would believe to the
common good many others have no faith in
it and they believe in a central
controlling power and so you have a
variety of opinion and it's very
controversial Milton Friedman the great
libertarian economists once said that
Adam Smith was as radical in his pronoun
promoting of lazy fair as we libertarian
economists are today and I think he had
an important point there so freedom is
is still very radical when we look at
the questions of legalizing drugs
whether we should allow immigrants to
come into our country whether we should
lower the drinking age from 21 to 18
very controversial as to whether we
should allow that sort of thing or not
and Adam Smith believed in the broadest
amount of maximum faith in freedom what
he called natural Liberty this his
system of natural Liberty and
essentially it was let's maximize the
amount of
freedom that people have economically
politically religiously let's introduce
competition and competition is a
critical element in Adam Smith's model
he hated monopolist and he had rather
disparaging things to say about business
people who tried to monopolize
government or industry now Leonard read
the founder of the the foundation that
I'm now president of the foundation for
economic education had a wonderful
example of the of the invisible hand and
used the example of the pencil Milton
Friedman used the example also in his
book free to choose and he said the
pencil is a great example of invisible
hand doctrine because you have thousands
if not millions of individuals involved
in the production of a simple little
pencil and it's they kind of the the raw
products of this pencil come from all
over the world the rubber from Brazil
perhaps the little metal here the iron
are from from Michigan the the wood
itself perhaps from the northwest and
the paint perhaps from Europe all over
the world and every one of them are
engaging in in a profit motive they
don't most of them don't even know
they're making a pencil and yet the end
result is something that we all benefit
from and it's called the pencil and we
use it today although we've we've tended
to use more pins and so forth and the
pencil is becoming more and more
obsolete but anyway Leonard read talks
about this and he says and it's funny
because no single individual can make
something as simple as a pencil it's a
delightful essay and i highly recommend
it we've reprinted it on our website
feed org just go there and you can read
it you can get one of our pamphlets I
pencil that Leonard read is put out okay
but then once the Adam Smith model was
developed and have this whole chapter
called it all started with Adam that was
going to be the original title of my
book but the publisher said no it'll end
up in the religious sections
so you better stick with the making of
modern economics which is you know kind
of a dry academic type title but inside
those 500 pages I've really tried to to
bring to life this great dramatic story
it's really the story of freedom taught
through the eyes and ears the the lives
of the great economic thinkers and I
start with Adam Smith but then comes
along the the counter plot those who who
who are fighting to fight freedom and
were opposed to the Smith model of
giving people free rein economically
especially and I talked about a number
of individuals who in fact some of Adam
Smith's disciples Ricardo and Malthus in
rather disparaging ways really gave the
the epitaph the the dismal science came
from Malthus and Ricardo and their iron
law of wages and subsistence level of
existence because of overpopulation and
not enough resources and what have you
Adam Smith was very optimistic but some
of his disciples are rather pessimistic
but the ultimate pessimist to capitalism
is described and we're going to play
some music now to represent this counter
Smith in this will be music number two
here and it builds and you kind of give
a sense of of who this economist is but
is he Adam Smith basically described his
model as a harmonious as harmonious a
harmony of interest and would be
socially orderly and there would be
universal opulence and there would be
stability in the Smith Ian system but
this enemy if you will of Smith was
quite the opposite he viewed capitalism
as alienating and exploitative
he saw instead of harmony of interest he
saw class interest in class struggle
instead of social order he saw chaos in
crisis instead of an invisible hand he
saw the the iron fist of capitalism and
that's represented by this music
kind of feels like Darth Vader has just
entered the room see anybody recognize
this music hosts the planets mars the
bringer of war
kind of dark and sinister okay and
indeed you know Marc's was a critic of
capitalism and he did have some insights
I talked in my chapter on marks which is
called marks madness plunges economics
into a new Dark Age so you kind of know
where I stand on marks but but marks did
make some positive contributions and I
talked about that at the end of my
chapter but overall I think he had a
negative impact in in the world
politically economically as a result of
marxism-leninism and we've gone through
a tremendous period of time of great
destructive powers in the name of
marxism marxism is as never really
caught on in the economics profession as
much as it has in sociology and
anthropology and other areas where has
made more positive contributions fact
I'll tell you an interesting story at
Rollins College we have a Marxist
professor in economics departments name
is Eric shuts and I had a fun time with
him one time I went into his office and
I presented him with a silver dollar and
I said I'd like to present this silver
dollar and give it to you as a gift and
and on one condition if you can name the
economist who died in the year this coin
was minted and if you look at the coin
it says 1883 and he looked at he says oh
that's easy I know who died it was Karl
Marx and I said that's right don't ever
forget it he's dead but Professor shirts
had a real good response he says yes but
I'm alive and that's very true on
college campuses Marxism is very much
alive and and dinesh de Sousa I see he's
in the audience would be our next
speaker and he'll tell you that Marxism
is very much alive on college campuses
but not so much in economics
there's a radical element of economics
there are Marx's like Professor shoots
and others but in large measure it
hasn't had the impact and the reason is
primarily because of the next group who
I don't have listed on here but they
would it would be one of the wings i've
got two wings for adam smith here and
one of the wings is the Austrian School
of Economics and if you want to start
playing some of the Austrian music and
I'll explain why I selected this
particular music it's a little bit it's
not as strong so you have to listen a
little bit more carefully but it's a
beautiful Walt though it doesn't start
out as a waltz as my wife points out to
me but eventually gets there anyway it
kind of builds rather slowly and then
you'll notice a rather significant
change in the music as as this is a
presenter so let's just take a moment
and listen to this wonderful waltz and
we'll see if you can if you can
recognize what what this is
you
this change
the Emperor's waltz and try now what
happens there when the music suddenly
rises dramatically it's by Strauss
Johann Strauss the Emperor enters the
room see it's just a pleasant music it's
just Pleasant music you know you're just
kind of listening and suddenly it rises
up very dramatically because the
Emperor's entered the room and who is
that Emperor and economics that that
countered this tremendous negative force
in economics it is carl menger and the
founding of the Austrian School of
Economics followed by his disciples
organ burn bhavik who is the finance
minister Austin in Austria for many
years and then became a professor and
then later on in the 20th century Ludwig
von Mises and Friedrich Hayek may have
may have heard of those names Hayek won
the Nobel Prize they're all from the
Austrian school well what was it from
the Austrian school that made this
dramatic a change and countered the
Marxist well one of the principles of
Marxism was the labor theory of value
that all all goods the value of goods
were based in the the labor embodied in
the production process and it d
legitimized the capitalist and the
landlord who were gaining profits and
interest and according to the Marxist
they really didn't deserve this the
whole product dessert was for the
laborers and the laborers therefore
should own the means of production and
that was accomplished through
nationalization and socialism and
central planning which is what the
Soviet model was based upon so what was
it that the Austrian said that counter
that and basically what manga did in his
principles of economics and I have a
whole chapter on this and it's called
out of the blue danube worked worked on
that title for some time the Austrians
carl menger and the Austrians reversed
the tide what was it that they
accomplished will they demonstrate am
angered
ticular demonstrated that cost was not
the determined the ultimate
determination of price that it was
dependent upon consumer demands and it
didn't matter how much something costs
if the consumer didn't want it the price
was not going to reflect the cost it was
going to reflect what what consumers
really wanted for so it's called the
theory of imputation and it was a
devastating critique of Marxism and the
other factors came from bham bhavik
mangers student who said there are two
reasons why capitalists and landlords
deserve interest in profits and one is
that the capitalist has to wait to be
paid the worker does not the workers
paid every two weeks or every week like
clockwork no matter what the accounts
receivables and accounts payables are
unless the company goes under so there's
no waiting that's required the other
factors the risk factor capitalists take
risks that workers do not and both of
those justify a higher profit margin and
the payment of interest and these were
devastating arguments to the marxist and
the marginalist revolution which was
part of this Austrian revival of smithy
and economics is basically was an
extremely important critical period of
history in the 1870s and history of
economics and the story of freedom and
what's amazing is that most histories of
thought missed that in fact this is
looking at a new history of economics
that didn't even mention manga by name
and yet noot noot Vic sell the great
Swedish economist who was a contemporary
of manga and an involve us and Jevons
who are considered the founders of the
margin school there's there's three
economist who discovered the marginal
marginalist revolution and it was Vic
cell that said it was the Austrians who
first propagated the concept of this
marginalist rebel
and the subjective value of consumer
goods and so forth so but that's been
lost in histories and I I put it back in
I put it back in as a critical role in
the history of the great economic
thinkers and then economics became a
science if you will Alfred Marshall the
Great British economist was the one who
changed the name from political economy
he wanted to imitate the physical
sciences many of you you know physics
you need to have a name like physics or
mathematics or logic so economics became
the word you see it sounded so much more
scientific and indeed the principles of
economics was the term that Alfred
Marshall used so as we entered the 20th
century there was one problem there was
one major problem in economics that had
not been resolved and in many ways even
to this day economics has not solved
this problem so even though my story
line ends on a positive note and I
talked about the triumph of market
economics and smithy and economics
there's still one troubling area and
that's in the area of money the
understanding of money the origin the
mystery of money and the role of central
banks and the chaotic conditions that
arise from time to time related to money
and this was an issue that was that
Irving Fisher grappled with his own
quantity theory of money failed him he
was the Milton Friedman of the early
20th century irving fisher from yale
university it failed him the quantity
theory of money which he basically
argued that if you didn't have a sharp
increase in in price in the price level
you couldn't have a depression so he
Fisher who was an Oracle of Wall Street
worth 10 million dollars in 1929 because
of one invention do you know what he
invented it's something every business
person uses every
anybody know it's the rolodex he
invented the rolodex and Remington Rand
bought his patent and he had 10 million
dollars of remington rand stock and so
he wanted the bull market and Wall
Street to continue forever so I was
wonderful accountant by the way Irving
Fisher is one of the most fascinating
economists and he's given short shrift
all the time in these history of thought
books I give him a whole chapter he's
absolutely fascinating but he ended his
life miserable yale university had to
buy his home and rent it to him rent
free because he lost everything in the
nineteen twenty-nine crash and it really
isn't an amazing story and so the big
issue is capitalism comes under its
greatest threat and I call it the Cannes
mutiny is my chapter Keynes mutiny the
introduction of John Maynard Keynes who
made a valiant attempt to save
capitalism from its own destruction from
this problem of money and so I have him
there and I have some music to represent
canes and his policy approach to solving
the problems that we encounter with the
Great Depression so listen to this music
anybody recognize this one khachaturian
say grenades well it doesn't change much
throughout this the entire music here so
you get a general image but what are we
talking about here what was his policy
prescription well in large measure you
know get the economy going
spin-spin-spin get the economy going as
fast as you can run deficits we can cut
it off at this point to get the general
idea and why did he believe that why did
he make such a central point that
government needed to be the the key
savior of a capitalist system and
basically goes back to the invisible
hand doctrine like more but not as bad
as Marx canes he he lacked faith that
the capitalist system could maintain its
stability and he questioned the
invisible hand doctrine well I have a
whole little section in my book called
Keynes the palm reader now I don't how
many of you knew this but Cain's
actually enjoyed reading people's hands
he would he was a he analyzed people's
hands so when he met you he wouldn't
look in your face he'd look at your
hands he would examine it when he met
FDR he was so carried away we're looking
at his hands and describing him that he
forgot to talk about deficit spending
and and this silver standard and so the
Depression continued you see for three
or four more years and if you read his
best book and it's the economic
consequences of the piece you need to
turn this around the economic
consequences of the piece there's a real
interesting account in there it's this
wonderful history that where he
describes the impact of the Versailles
peace accords after World War one and he
stormed out of the Versailles peace
accords he was part of the British
delegation there and he stormed out and
the reason he stormed out was because he
knew that
consequences of this draconian policies
and of course that included all these
reparations and billions of dollars of
referee or of German marks and he knew
it would result in hyperinflation and
even predict swore in this book economic
consequences of his piece of the piece
was his first bestseller and in my
opinion his greatest work beautifully
written and very accurate in prediction
well in the beginning he describes each
one of the political figures who was
there and so he describes Woodrow Wilson
from the United States as a rather weak
man and wheat president why because his
hands were were weak when he shook his
hands he he was not impressed and Lloyd
George on the hand ruff ruff individual
overbearing and indeed that's the kind
of hands he describes and then he comes
to Clemens who the president of France
he wore gloves very disappointed and so
I say in my book and now you understand
why why Keynes had so much problems with
the invisible hand doctrine of Adam
Smith is the economist can't have a
little bit of humor you see all right
well my final individual kind of saves
the day for capitalism but the chapter
this is called milton's paradise named
after Milton Friedman his
counter-revolution his monetary
counter-revolution extremely critical in
the history of economics and this was
while holla Broner made such a major
blunder in ignoring Friedman you cannot
ignore Friedman's contribution he won
the Nobel Prize appropriately in 1976
200 years after Adam Smith's because he
embodies the Adam Smith vision of the
invisible hand doctrine he's the one who
restored almost single-handedly faith in
capitalism that it can function on its
own and it can rise up out of the dust
and and doesn't have to plunge us into
some great economic Cataclysm and he
actually he wrote the book a monetary
history of the United States with anise
towards this magnificent empirical work
where he actually invented m1 and m2 you
know we all have these descriptions of
money supply that didn't exist in the
30s and so the view was always held that
the government did everything they can
the Federal Reserve did everything they
can to keep the Great Depression from
happening but they failed miserably and
so you needed fiscal policy to intervene
well Friedman proved that old theory
wrong and he did it with one page out of
800 pages in a monetary history the book
is worth buying for one page not just
one page but one paragraph and not just
one paragraph one single sentence and
you know what the sentence is the money
supply declined by over one-third from
nineteen twenty nine to nineteen
thirty-two and the Federal Reserve was
not impotent but in fact it was a
demonstration of their incredible power
because the Federal Reserve engineered
and allowed to take place certainly the
Great Depression because of the collapse
of the money supply which was totally
unnecessary so it was a result of Milton
Friedman this base this argument has
convinced over time more and more
economists and it was for that reason in
my opinion that he won and deserve the
Nobel Prize and has the tremendous
influence that hey that he has today
nevertheless despite all of this despite
the triumph of market economics and
there's certainly the collapse of the
berlin wall and the collapse of soviet
communism and china adopting capitalism
is all very much in the friedman model
and also the 20th century i would be
remiss to leave out Mises and Hayek
Ludwig von Mises was the one who said
socialism cannot work and halle Broner
who for many years of socialists finally
admitted in The New Yorker me caes was
right it's right in print
in in 1989 1990 so that's that's really
an amazing admission so me season-high
accan if you saw the PBS series and the
commanding heights you saw the influence
of Mises and Hayek in in dealing with
the central planning arguments of
socialism so my final chapter is called
dr. Smith goes to Washington the triumph
of market economics and indeed I think
it has triumphed in many ways but the
problem is you still have the money
problem the Federal Reserve how much
faith is Alan Greenspan a devotee of
Iran and yet how much faith is Alan
Greenspan have that the market will
recover on its own well I question how
much faith he has in that kind of a
system I question how much of a devotees
of Adam Smith's invisible hand doctrine
kind of suspect that he believes a
little bit more in the visible hand of
stimulating the economy with increasing
the money supply or tightening and
playing the the boom-bust cycle that
we've all experienced over the last few
years so the business cycle is not over
the recession's or are not over we're
going to see more of these as a result
because we just haven't found a solution
is that the gold standard we seem to be
very fearful of the gold standard which
has been the tradition of the Austrian
school and what is the money supply if
you increase the money at a steady rate
so these are kinds of the issues that I
end but my heroic figure Adam Smith
comes back to life after almost lying
dead as a result of Cannes as a result
of marks and then in the canes and the
the Great Depression but he somehow
comes alive and but I ultimately end up
with with the great quote from from
Milton Friedman and George Stigler say
that freedom is a rare and delicate
flower we must treat it carefully thank
you very much
oh and when we finish the question and
answer i'll put on the music that i have
for milton friedman's not quite yet
first question mark I understand you
were not always an advocate of Adam
Smith how did your conversion come about
yeah that's that's true because what
happened was when I first started
writing this book it was a very cynical
book I was actually under the influence
of the libertarian economist Murray
Rothbard who has written some brilliant
things and and I was really caught up in
in what rothbard had to say more than
Friedman in the early part of my career
and so so rothbard had actually
commissioned him in 1980 to write a kind
of a contra howl Broner history of
thought was supposed to be 12 chapters
long and in 300 pages and written in one
year in 15 years later he wrote half the
book and that was 2,000 pages long
because it wasn't what I was intending
but in the book he has this chapter
called the celebrated Adam Smith and
it's a very negative assessment of Adam
Smith basically saying that is that Adam
Smith had this labor theory of value
concept as part of his theory and it led
to Ricardo and the labor theory of value
in Marxism so so he really rothbard
really criticized Adam Smith and I was
caught up in that as I was writing the
book and I took my first chapter out to
Utah and I was meeting with my uncle
cleone who many of you may have known
cleon skousen in a long time
conservative and and I was talking to
him and he said you know it's it's a
funny thing I was telling him about my
book and he says a funny thing the Adam
Smith doctor and the invisible hand
doctrine is inspired of God and it just
took me aback I thought you know maybe
I'm making a mistake taking going down
this road of the
rothbard view a negative view of adam
smith and so i was writing this book in
fact my original title was called the
propensity to confuse and a little play
on Keynes's propensity to consume but as
a very negative and dark book and one
and I said well who's ride is rothbard
riders my uncle cleone right and so I
decided you know there's only one way to
find out so I picked up a copy of the
wealth of nations and I read it
cover-to-cover to make up my own mind
and it took me quite a little time to do
that but when I was all through I put
the book down and I said my uncle is
right in murray rothbard is wrong and it
completely changed my outlook and it's
amazing the book just exploded in terms
of interest and i was able to create
this plot and everything that I'm
telling you about so I know I made the
right decision to a certain extent you
have answered this next question um
they're actually a couple that will put
together one was could you name your top
five economist of all time and also the
worst five economist you kind of address
that already but you might want to go
back to it and then out of the the field
of contemporary economists who do you
think will be the next great economist
who is up and coming in the field well
you could give a whole speech on on what
my five favorite are my five worst but
I'd like to just focus on a couple of
economists that are often ignored
jean-baptiste say is one of the greatest
economists and says law is profound and
it's been totally misunderstood as a
result of canes and and Stephen Cade's
from the Australian Chamber of Commerce
has written a wonderful book called
saves law and the Keynesian a revolution
and he demonstrates very clearly our
understanding of say certainly say in
basquiat as well the French tradition
not even at oakville Alexis de
Tocqueville in that category the great
French lays a fair school deserves a lot
more credit they also i also have right
in the middle of my book kind of a time
where you just sit back and in
i er the beauty of the neo-classical
structure of economics that had been
built up until time of alfred marshall
and normally at that time period they
all the other books bring in the
criticisms of forced in belen on on the
capitalist system and that's that's all
the person they have and i discovered
there's a there was an economist who
considered himself an economist even
though he's considered one of the
founders of sociology and that's moxa a
beber Faber max Faber deserves much more
interest among economists and I have a
whole chapter about his Protestant ethic
in his discussion of religion so
certainly would put him in that category
Fisher of course in the 20th century my
chapter on me sees is called the missing
me sees because he's missing all the
time in these other books he certainly
deserves a lot more interest and
certainly Rothbard does too in today's
world there's there's two areas there's
lots of areas of economics that are
interesting experimental economics I I
find absolutely fascinating that work by
vernon smith and who's now at George
Mason University and also like what
Roger garrison is doing at Auburn his
book time and money is an excellent book
but we need to do more empirical work to
to support the Austrian school like the
like like the Chicago School is done the
Chicago School has just had tremendous
success with its empirical studies to
support its theoretical underpinnings
and the Austrians have shied away from
empirical studies over the years and I
think that's been a mistake we have a
couple of questions about what other
economists have said about mark I mean
about Adam Smith first Emma Rothschilds
economic sentiments in which she
discusses Adam Smith what do you think
of that and also marks site Smith
repeatedly in his work as part of the
foundation of his theory did marks view
Smith as an enemy
well I certainly is true that marks red
Smith that when he was at the London
library and and but he focused primarily
on Ricardo it was Ricardo that took
economics down the dangerous road I call
a tricky Ricardo is my chapter on
Ricardo and he is very tricky because he
has very positive contributions and then
very negative things and and it you know
Ricardo drew out the labor theory of
some of the labor theory from Smith but
it's primarily his own focus that that
marks drew upon and I think overall Marx
was pretty negative about Adam Smith as
far as Emma Rothschilds I haven't read
her book yet I've got a copy of it she
sent it to me as a matter of fact I
haven't read it and I so I'll reserve
judgment on on hers but she talks about
several other French economist which I
found really interesting so it's nice to
see some of these other great economists
being brought to the forefront okay we
have some theoretical questions but we
also have some questions about fee so
I'm going to do those first because
they're faster one one one person said
I'm curious to know how many people here
have been to a fee seminar in the past
50 years so if maybe we could just do a
show of hands of those of you who my
goodness this is a great number I would
say at least a third have been to feast
seminars related to that a person asks
would Milton Friedman consider coming to
fee fest 2003 and does Friedman stay in
touch with fee very much and I do want
to talk about Friedman's relationship
with fee and yeah the foundation for
economic education was founded by
Leonard read as I mentioned the author
of eye pencil started in 1946 and it's
been an interesting cycle if you will
the relationship between
the Chicago School see if you have the
two wings up there with Adam Smith you
have the Austrian school on one side and
the Chicago School on the other and I
see them more cooperative than you know
the more friends than foes and as Milton
Friedman said well really their friends
and foes and there are just areas where
they agree in areas they disagree and
fee has been kind of in the middle of
that and for a while I remember 1946 one
of the very first essays that fee
published was a roofs or ceilings by
Milton Friedman and George Stigler
arguing for deregulation of the rent
controls in New York City and it was
considered quite controversial is
reviewed very negatively in the american
economic review it's just amazing you
know saying that oh yeah we should keep
these rent controls in New York then
they had a falling out and Mises and
Hayek especially me sees he he taught
regularly at fee and there was a real
strong Austrian band in fact Larry
Wimmer my mentor at Brigham Young
University he went to the University of
Chicago and was a devotee of freedmen so
he went to a fee seminar one time and he
said the that there were two nuns from
South Africa who were socialists and
they were treated better than Larry
Wimmer was because he was from Chicago I
mean it's a very funny story and and one
time Larry Wimmer went up and drew a
supply and demand curve on the board and
they went over and erased it no no we
don't want no graphs it's all verbal and
so that was kind of the negative part
but now it's starting to come back and
in fact I've always felt I have one foot
in the Austrian School in one foot in
the Chicago School in school and I'm a
very close friend of a Milton Friedman
and I also gave the last private
interview to friedrich hayek never got
to meet me caes but I've always
considered both schools a really
valuable contribution to to this area
and so
in the last issue of ideas on liberty we
had milton friedman write an article for
us called my five favorite libertarian
books so you you might want to pick up
that issue I our time is up
unfortunately it's been a great session
and we're glad to have all of you here
and we're glad to have had mark skousen
I telling us about his book okay we're
gonna take a short break here and then
i'll introduce dinesh d'souza so in five
minutes yep mark skousen is the
president of the foundation for economic
education he's the author of several
books including the making of modern
economics the lives and ideas of the
great thinkers it's published by any
sharp and you can visit them online at
Emmy sharp calm